foreign
what's wrong
that's the foot it feels like we should
be happier any pain I want to make it do
happy people in bright colors
maybe it's one of those places that you
only go once and never return oh like
Soul cycle
Chicago
this is very different now our heroes
into the city of Chicago who is he
talking to at one point a lot of
musicals had narrators sorry go ahead
really do I have your permission uh oh
he's peppery
[Music]
[Applause]
clearly we're in the next era of
musicals here we shock you these
musicals are darker
[Music]
more sex Oh yay and violence
how are we supposed to make a happy
ending here these musicals don't have
happy endings
sounds like someone needs a lesson in
the power of Happiness who wants to get
naked what I need is a lawyer once I've
worked my magic no jury will ever
convict your hubby even if he kills
again Josh didn't do it uh-huh
[Applause]
[Music]
girl
need my help to answer that question no
thank you